D'où viennent les nuages
c'est typiquement le genre de questions que les enfants posent et auquelles on ne sait pas toujours très bien répondre
vous savez vous ce qu'est vraiment un nuage et comment il se forme alors si vous n'êtes pas certains la réponse
rassurez vous, vous n'êtes pas les seuls, en fait, même les scientifiques n'ont pas encore tout compris à la formation des nuages
et pire on va voir que en théorie les nuages ne devraient même pas exister
Les nuages jouent un rôle essentiel pour notre planète.
D'abord, évidemment, ils participent au cycle de l'eau puisqu'ils sont à l'origine des précipitations
et donc, d'eux dépens le fait qu'on puisse avoir des inondations ou des sécheresses dans une zone ou une autre
mais les nuages ont également une influence forte sur les équilibres climatiques
c'est lié au fait qu'ils réfléchissent une partie de la lumière du soleil et diminuent donc la quantité d'énergie que la terre reçoit
les nuages couvrent en moyenne les deux tiers de la surface de la planète
et si ils n'y en avaient pas, eh bien, il ferait beaucoup plus chaud
les nuages sont d'ailleurs un des facteurs d'incertitude les plus importants dans les modèles climatiques actuels
c'est pourquoi mieux comprendre leur formation est absolument essentiel pour correctement reconstruire les climats passés et simuler l'effet du réchauffement climatique
bon donc c'est quoi un nuage eh bien on va commencer par l'explication traditionnelle au niveau des océans de l'eau s'évapore
ça se produit aussi dans une moindre mesure au dessus des continents et notamment des forêts
cette évaporation c'est de la transformation d'eau liquide en vapeur d'eau
vapeur qui ensuite part dans l'atmosphère
en tant que gaz la vapeur d'eau est plus légère que le diazote ou le dioxygène qui composent l'air
donc elle a tendance à monter
et sauf qu'en altitude il fait de plus en plus froid, on perd environ 1 degré tous les 150 m et en se refroidissant
la vapeur d'eau fini par se recondenser c'est-à-dire qu'elle redevient de l'eau liquide
alors attention ça veut pas dire tout de suite qui pleut, l'eau forme des gouttelettes qui sont d'abord
minuscules et qui restent en suspension dans l'air tant qu'elles ne sont pas trop grosses c'est à dire à peu près en dessous d'un millimètre
mais ces fines gouttelettes deviennent visibles parce qu'elles diffusent la lumière
c'est à dire qu'un rayon lumineux qui les frappe se trouve renvoyé dans toutes les directions
et c'est pour ça qu'on voit des nuages dans le ciel
ce qui est important dans cette explication
c'est le fait que la vapeur d'eau, au départ, elle est invisible, elle ne se voit pas, et c'est seulement après condensation en petites gouttelettes
d'eau liquide qu'on voit quelque chose
pour les pros de l'apéro le phénomène ressemble un peu à celui qui explique la couleur du pastis et je vous renvoie à ma vidéo
sur le sujet, cette histoire de vapeur d'eau qui se condense c'est aussi ce qui se produit juste au dessus d'une casserole ou d'une bouilloire
ça, cette espèce de fumée blanche, eh bien ça n'est pas de la vapeur d'eau, la vapeur d'eau c'est invisible
ce qu'on voit ici c'est vraiment de l'eau liquide, dans la bouilloire l'eau bout à 100°, elle se transforme donc en vapeur
puis au contact de l'air qui est à environ 20 degrés la vapeur se refroidit et redevient liquide
elle se condense en formant des minuscules gouttelettes et ce sont ces gouttelettes qu'on voit parce qu'elles diffusent la lumière
tel que je le dis on a envie de penser que les nuages et ce qu'on voit s'échapper de la bouilloire c'est la même chose
mais il y a un truc qui cloche dans cette explication, c'est pas la même chose
l'eau des océans elle bout pas, elle est jamais à 100°
et en fait plus généralement pourquoi est-ce qu'on a de la vapeur d'eau dans l'air
l'air ambiant il est à moins de 100 degrés donc normalement à cette température là l'eau est liquide, il devrait pas y avoir de vapeur
et bien pour éclaircir ça, on va reprendre un peu les choses à la base, et essayer de comprendre au départ pourquoi l'eau s'évapore
c'est un truc qu'on a tous appris, il existe principalement trois états de la matière: solide, liquide, et gaz
et le cas de l'eau est bien connue, elle devient solide en dessous de zéro degré, c'est la glace
et gazeuse au dessus de 100 degrés, c'est la vapeur d'eau
ok mais en même temps on sait qu'il ya la vapeur d'eau dans l'air, et puis on voit bien les flaques sèchent
disparaissent même si il fait pas 100 degrés, l'eau des flaques ne bout pas et pourtant elle s'évapore quand même
alors je me souviens qu'au lycée, on nous répétait de bien faire la différence entre l'ébullition et l'évaporation
mais sans vraiment nous expliquer pourquoi ce n'était pas le même phénomène et pourquoi ça se produisait à des températures si différentes
alors si comme moi vous n'avez jamais vraiment bien compris cette histoire je vais essayer de vous l'expliquer et on va voir que
ébullition et évaporation
c'est en fait fondamentalement le même phénomène
La clé pour comprendre cette histoire d'évaporation c'est que pour connaître l'état solide, liquide, ou gazeux d'une matière, il n'y a pas que la
température qui compte, il y a aussi la pression
voici ce qu'on appelle un diagramme de phase, c'est le diagramme de phase de l'eau
vous avez la température en abscisses et la pression en ordonnée, attention l'échelle est un peu spécial
et le diagramme vous indique l'état de l'eau en fonction de ces deux critères
par exemple dans les conditions ambiantes il fait, mettons, 20 degrés et 1 bar de pression
on est là dans le diagramme, donc l'eau est liquide
si vous refroidissez en dessous de zéro degré, tout en restant à un bar, et bien l'eau devient solide et forme de la glace
et au dessus de 100 degrés, toujours à un bar de pression, on passe en forme gazeuse la vapeur
mais si on change de pression par exemple qu'on se place à deux barres
et bien l'eau restera liquide jusqu'à 120 degrés, et c'est le principe de la cocotte minute
bon je pense que vous voyez à peu près comment on utilisent ce genre de diagrammes, c'est pas très compliqué
et pourtant il ya un truc très important qu'on nous explique pas toujours très bien à son sujet
on a dit il y a deux choses qui comptent, la température, et la pression
alors la température, c'est la température, y a pas trop d'ambiguïté, mais concernant la pression, il est important de bien comprendre qui met la pression
prenez un récipient contenant de l'eau par exemple une bassine à une température de 20 degrés
la pression de l'air au dessus est de 1 bar, la pression ambiante
mais l'eau aussi possède une pression, et en fait, si on se met juste en dessous de la surface c'est la même c'est un bar
il y a un équilibre, les pressions sont identiques de chaque côté
maintenant, mettons nous à la place d'un petit volume d'eau dans la bassine
ce volume d'eau est à une température de 20 degrés donc, et il subit une pression de 1 bar
et qui lui mais cette pression?  Et bien, c'est l'eau qui l'entoure
il est soumis à un bar de pression d'eau, une pression qui est causée par l'eau environnante
dans le diagramme 1 bar, 20 degrés on a vu que ce petit volume d'eau est censé être à l'état liquide
et c'est le cas donc tout va bien, maintenant mettons nous à la place de l'eau qui se trouve en surface
elle subit aussi une pression de 1 bar, mais qui lui est mise par qui? Et bien par l'air au dessus
or l'air, ça n'est pas de l'eau, et donc c'est de la pression qui ne compte pas pour se positionner dans le diagramme
c'est ça la clé du raisonnement, dans le diagramme de phase de l'eau ce qu'on considère sur l'axe vertical quand on parle de pression
c'est uniquement la pression de l'eau et donc pour l'eau qui est en surface bin y'en a pas, c'est zéro bar si vous voulez
donc dans le diagramme, on est quelque part par là dans une zone où l'eau est censée être gazeuse
et c'est pour ça qu'à la surface, l'eau liquide se transforme en vapeur, elle s'évapore
vous voyez que ça n'a rien de mystérieux ou fondamentalement différent de l'ébullition
on utilise le même diagramme mais c'est la pression de l'eau qui compte et cette pression d'eau elle est différente dans les deux situations
les molécules d'eau qui sont au milieu de la bassine elle voit une pression d'eau de 1 bar
mais pour celles qui sont en surface la pression d'eau c'est zéro
alors en fait zéro c'est pas tout à fait vrai, vu que des molécules d'eau s'évapore pour aller dans l'air et bien l'air devient humide
c'est à dire qu'il n'est plus seulement composé de diazote et de dioxygène mais aussi de vapeur d'eau
et ces molécules bougent dans tous les sens, et donc elles exercent une certaine pression sur leurs copines qui sont restées à la surface de
la bassine, et pour savoir quelle pression elles exercent, bin c'est facile, on fait juste une règle de trois
si l'air est à une pression totale de 1 bar et qu'il est composé à environ
79% de diazotet et 21% de dioxygène et qu'on imagine qu'il contienne, disons
0.5 pour cent de vapeur d'eau, et bien, la pression exercée par la vapeur d'eau sera
0,005 bar, 5 millibars
voyons dans le diagramme ce que cette pression de 5 mbars d'eau implique pour les molécules de la surface
sachant qu'on est toujours à 20 degrés
eh ben on voit que malgré cette légère pression d'eau les molécules qui sont à la surface sont encore censées passer dans l'état gazeux donc
s'évaporer et donc à 20 degrés si l'air est composé de
0.5 pour cent de vapeur d'eau et bien le processus d'évaporation va quand même continuer
l'air peut encore se charger en vapeur d'eau et on voit sur le diagramme que ça peut durer jusqu'à ce que la pression de vapeur d'eau
soit d'environ 23 mbars et là on arrive à la frontière avec l'état liquide et donc l'évaporation cesse
et donc quand on en arrive là l'air ne peut plus accueillir de vapeur d'eau on dit qu'il est saturé c'est ce qu'on appelle 100
% d'humidité
alors attention 100 % d'humidité, ça veut pas dire que l'air est composé à 100% de vapeur d'eau
ça veut dire qu'il est au maximum de ce qu'il peut accueillir
et ce qui est important à avoir en tête, c'est que cette quantité de vapeur qui fait qu'on atteint 100 % d'humidité
et bien elle dépend de la température
on a dit qu à 20° c'était 23 mbars de pression, mais vous voyez sur le diagramme qu'à une température de disons 35 degrés
eh bien, il aurait fallu aller à 56 millibars pour être sur la frontière
donc 23 millibars de pression de vapeur d'eau c'est 100 % d'humidité quand il fait 20 degrés, mais c'est seulement environ
41% du maximum quand il fait 35 degrés
et c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça l'humidité relative
c'est en pourcentage du maximum de ce qu'elle pourrait être et qui dépend de la température
alors un petit mot quand même pour vous expliquer ce qui se passe au niveau microscopique
on a dit que quand on atteint 100 % d'humidité relative l'évaporation cesse
on a un peu l'impression qu'à la surface de la bassine les molécules se passent le mot du genre ah ça y est il fait
100% d'humidité, on arrête de s'évaporer, alors non, c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
en permanence, des molécules d'eau s'échappent de la surface, s'évaporent
et plus la température est élevée plus c'est le cas, et à l'inverse, en permanence des molécules d'eau de l'air
viennent se condenser à la surface et ce d'autant plus que l'air est humide
et quand l'humidité de l'air atteint 100% c'est le seuil où les deux flux se compensent, donc même à 100 % d'humidité
il y a toujours des molécules qui s'évaporent, mais en fait autant qui se condensent, et donc la quantité d'eau dans la bassine reste constante
bien, en conclusion, vous voyez que évaporation et ébullition c'est vraiment le même combat c'est juste la pression de l'eau qui diffère
pour les molécules qui sont situées en surface
eh bien c'est la pression de vapeur d'eau qui compte
et pour celles qui sont au milieu de la bassine c'est la pression de l'eau qui en fait est égale à la pression totale de
l'air
et quand on chauffe l'eau de la bassine
au delà de 100 degrés et bien même un bar de pression d'eau n'est plus suffisant pour garder les molécules à l'état liquide
elle passe à l'état gazeux et donc ça fait des bulles de vapeur au sein du liquide
et c'est pour ça que l'ébullition a lieu au coeur du liquide alors que l'évaporation seulement en surface
bien maintenant qu'on a clarifié cette histoire d'évaporation revenons aux mécanismes de formation des nuages
On l'a dit sur terre en permanence de l'eau s'évapore principalement au niveau des océans
cette évaporation elle peut se produire parce que l'humidité relative au niveau de la surface est inférieure à 100 % l'air est rarement complètement saturé
cet air chargé en vapeur d'eau s'élève et finit par être refroidi dans les couches supérieures de l'atmosphère
dans le diagramme de phase de l'eau ça correspond à un mouvement de ce genre par exemple
la pression de vapeur d'eau reste identique mais la température diminue ce qui fait une augmentation de l'humidité relative
jusqu'au point où la vapeur devrait en principe revenir de l'eau liquide alors je dis bien en principe parce qu'il ya une subtilité
le passage de l'état gazeux à l'état liquide la condensation ne se fait pas de manière si simple
100 % d'humidité c'est en fait le seuil théorique à dépasser pour que la vapeur d'eau commence à se condenser mais sur une surface plane
quand une gouttelette se forme et bien ça n'est pas une surface plane c'est une surface courbée et même très courbée hein vu que les
gouttelettes au départ sont minuscules, or pour se condenser sur une surface courbée, 100 % d'humidité ça ne suffit pas
il faut que la pression de vapeur d'eau soit supérieure à celle correspondant à 100 % d'humidité
intuitivement la raison c'est que les molécules s'échappent plus facilement d'une surface courbe que d'une surface plane
et ce d'autant plus que la courbure est forte et donc il faut un peu plus de vapeur pour compenser on appelle ça l'effet kelvin
la courbe que vous voyez ici représente l'humidité relative qu'il faut pour que la vapeur d'eau se condense en une goutte en fonction de son
diamètre, plus la goutte est petite plus l'humidité relative doit être importante
sauf que les gouttes elles naissent pas grosses, elles doivent commencer par être petites avant de grossir
par exemple on lit sur le diagramme que pour que des molécules d'eau sous forme de vapeur
puis se regrouper et former une gouttelette de disons de nanomètres eh bien il faut que l'air soit à
170 % d'humidité
quand l'air contient plus de vapeur d'eau que le seuil correspondant à 100 % d'humidité on dit qu'il est sursaturé
et ça se produit par exemple très bien au dessus de votre bouilloire
ce qui sort de la bouilloire c'est de la vapeur à 100 degrés et un bar de pression
et quand elle est refroidie brutalement à 20 degrés et bien on a un bar de vapeur d'eau
alors que 100 % d'humidité c'est pour 23 millibars on l'a dit donc on est à 4300 % d'humidité relative
on est très sursaturé
mais dans l'atmosphère des telles saturations se produisent pour ainsi dire jamais
par exemple ici vous avez des mesures d'humidité relative effectuées
à différentes hauteurs en plein milieu d'un nuage
et bin on n'arrive même pas à 101% donc on est très loin des conditions qui permettent à un nuage de pouvoir se former spontanément
et du coup la conclusion est sans appel, en théorie les nuages ne devraient pas pouvoir se former sur la terre
sauf que les nuages bin on en voit, donc ils existent, c'est qu'ils arrivent à se former même, s'il n'y a que des toutes petites
sursaturations dans l'atmosphère, alors comment ça fonctionne et bien la solution du mystère a été proposée par le métérologue suédois Hilding Keller
Keller le premier a compris que les minuscules gouttelettes d'eau qui constituent les nuages ne se forment pas à partir de rien
mais grâce à l'aide de petites particules qui vont faciliter l'initiation de la condensation, on les appelle des noyaux de condensation
imaginez une petite particule sphérique de, mettons, 100 nanomètres
si de l'eau se condense à sa surface, la courbure sera évidemment moins importante que si la même quantité d'eau s'était condensée sur elle même
et donc l'effet kelvin sera moins fort
si on reprend la courbe qui donne la sursaturation
nécessaires en fonction de la courbure et bien on voit qu'avec des noyaux de condensation de 100 nanomètres
ça commence à devenir possible avec des sursaturation de seulement 101 %
bon tout ça est très bien sur le papier, mais d'où ils sortiraient ces noyaux de condensation
et bien il faut savoir que l'atmosphère est pleine de minuscules particules qu'on appelle des aérosols
il y en a en moyenne dix mille par centimètre cube
alors dix mille c'est vraiment une moyenne de situations très différentes puisque ça va de moins d'un millier dans les environnements naturels
à plusieurs dizaines de milliers dans des environnements urbains pollués
du point de vue de leurs compositions ces particules peuvent être de tout un tas de nature, et ça dépend beaucoup de l'environnement
des poussières minérales, des cristaux de sel de mer, des suies, mais aussi des gouttelettes d'acide sulfurique ou de sulfate d'ammonium
ou encore des composés organiques
et ce sont toutes ces particules qui permettent d'initier la condensation de la vapeur d'eau en liquide et donc de former des nuages
d'ailleurs cette activation du changement d'état ressemble un peu à ce qui se passe pour la formation des bulles de champagne
vous pouvez aller voir ma vidéo sur le sujet
ouais champagne, pastis, moi j'aime bien faire la physico-chimie à l'apéro, en conclusion sans ces particules plus ou moins naturelles qui servent de noyaux
de condensation
les nuages ne pourraient pas se former
ce qui compte avec ces particules on l'a vu c'est principalement leur taille mais il y a aussi un effet de leur composition chimique
on appelle ça l'effet Raout si de la vapeur condense sous forme liquide sur un noyau de condensation
et bien elle peut commencer à le dissoudre en partie
et donc la gouttelette se trouvera être un mélange d'eau et de molécules provenant de la particule
et ça va réduire le phénomène d'évaporation en surface puisque en quelque sorte ces molécules qui ne sont pas de l'eau vont bloquer une partie
de la surface pour l'évaporation
et donc en plus de l'effet de taille, la nature chimique des aérosols va faciliter la condensation de la vapeur d'eau et donc la formation
des nuages mais, il existe encore un dernier phénomène favorable lui aussi d'origine chimique
le fait que dans certaines particules on retrouve des substances qu'on appelle des tensioactifs
les tensioactifs ce sont des molécules comme par exemple des molécules de savon qui viennent se placer à la surface de l'eau et qui réduisent
la difficulté de créer des surfaces très courbées
et de même que le savon permet plus facilement de faire des bulles, et bien les tensioactifs vont réduire l'effet kelvin
et ce qui est amusant dans cette affaire c'est que la plupart des substances tensioactifs qui facilitent la formation des nuages sont vraisemblablement d'origine biologique
c'est à dire que la présence de la vie et pas seulement les activités humaines joue un rôle dans la formation des nuages
ça peut paraître étonnant que la présence du vivant puisse faciliter l'existence des nuages on aurait pu croire que c'était un phénomène purement physique
et pourtant il existe un cas qui ressemble beaucoup qui est très intéressant ce sont les canons à neige
dans cet épisode uniquement parlé de la formation des nuages formés de gouttelettes liquides les nuages chauds, en quelque sorte
mais il existe aussi des nuages de glace comme les cyrus qu'on retrouve à plus haute altitude
et le principe du canon à neige c'est justement de créer un nuage de glace à partir d'eau et d'air sous pression et ce en
quelques instants et dans certaines situations pour faciliter la transformation de l'eau en glace on utilise une bactérie
cette bactérie s'appelle pseudomonas synringae et elle possède une propriété
assez étonnante celle de pouvoir faciliter la congélation de l'eau même à des températures
très proche de zéro degré et donc on utilise dans certains canons à neige pour pouvoir faciliter la production d'une belle poudreuse blanche
vous y penserez cet hiver si vous allez dévaler les pistes
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à partager pouces bleus la cloche roussat
vous pouvez retrouver les actus la chaîne sur facebook et sur twitter et ceux qui souhaitent le veut soutenir sur typique merci à bientôt